just days after he became the
highest-ranking member of the Roman
Catholic Church to be convicted of child
sex abuse videotape has emerged showing
Australian Cardinal George Pell being
interviewed by police in Rome Seth Doane
is in Rome this morning with more Seth
good morning good morning Cardinal
George Pell who is now behind bars
awaiting sentencing was once the
Vatican's treasurer and a top adviser to
Pope Francis now in this newly released
video we are seeing his indignant
reaction to the charges he faced that
was Pelle in the 2016 exchange with
police at the time the top ranking
Cardinal was learning details of the
charges against him they did abused two
thirteen-year-old choir boys in 1996
when he was the Archbishop of Melbourne
the video released Friday by the
Melbourne Court reveals hints of what
would later make up the Cardinals so far
unsuccessful defense all along he has
maintained his innocence his legal team
has filed an appeal the Vatican will
handle its own investigation news of the
guilty verdict in civil court was
released just after the Holy See's
landmark sexual abuse summit father hon
Zollner was one of the organisers can
you envision a scenario where the
Vatican comes up with a different
conclusion than the Australian courts I
don't think so bail is no longer in
charge of the finance ministry the 77
year old faces up to 50 years in prison
he will be sentenced March 13th for CBS
this morning Saturday Seth Doane roll